All right,
let's move onto drawing rectangles now.
The first interesting
thing about rectangles,
is that they can be drawn with
two different shape types.
They can either be drawn with shape
type line, just to get the outlines of
the rectangles, or shape type
filled to fill in the rectangles.
Let's go with filled for now.
shapeRenderer.rect is overloaded with
about a dozen different functions to
do different things.
Honestly, to have a look at them
all you should probably just
check out the documentation.
The basic version though,
draws an access aligned rectangle,
starting with the lower left corner and
then giving the width and the height.
Let's try running this.
So far, so good.
Let's do something more interesting.
We can do some super fun
stuff with the colors and
rectangles, like specifying a color for
each corner.
Let's try this.
There we go,
the rectangle smoothly transitions
between the colors at the corners.
These next two rectangles
are being drawn in such a way that
one's going to overlap the other.
So, which one do you think
is going to come out on top?
Is it this red one,
which is being drawn first, or
the green one that's being drawn second?
Ha, look like the green one wins.
When shape render is asked to
draw things on top of each other
it uses what's called
the painter's algorithm.
Just like the initial layers of paint
laid down by a painter get covered up
by what gets pained later, similarly,
shapes that are drawn later on will
cover up shapes that were drawn earlier.
We can also use shape render
to draw rotated rectangles.
Now here's where the signature of
rect starts getting pretty crazy and
the documentation will come in handy.
Again, here is the bottom left corner,
and here's the width and height now.
And this entry is the origin
about which we'll be rotating.
So if the width and height are both 100,
then 50/50 is right in
the middle of the rectangle.
Then we have the x scale,
the y scale, and rotation.
So, we're drawing this 100 by 100, but
then we're going to squash it by 50%
horizontally, and
rotate it by 45 degrees.
Same thing with this one, except
we're going to rotate it 135 degrees.
Let's check out what this looks like.
Cool.
So we've got two rectangles that were
drawn at the same spot.
They were smashed by 50% horizontally,
and
then the yellow one was
rotated by 45 degrees.
So it was initially straight up and
down, and now it's tilted to the left.
And the green one has been
rotated by 135 degrees.
To more easily understand what's
going on with this origin parameter,
let's try something very similar.
The setup is almost identical,
but instead of the origin being
in the middle of the rectangle,
the origin is now down at the bottom
left corner of the rectangle.
So now, the rectangle's instead of
being rotated about their center,
are being rotated about
this bottom left corner.
OpenGL has an interesting quirk.
It knows how to draw in filled shapes,
but
it doesn't know how to draw thick lines.
So if we want a thick line,
what we actually need is just a rotated,
super skinny rectangle.
Thankfully, shapeRenderer gives
us a super simple way to do this.
It's called rectLine.
We give it the x and the y position
of the start of the line, the x and
y position of the end of the line,
and the thickness.
And there we go, we get a fat line.
[LAUGH] All right, last thing,
time for some silliness.
Let's draw a rainbow flower, this
might come in handy for the next quiz.
Pretty cool, right?